Hi, my name is Nick, and I am the product
manager for Google Chrome's extension system.
Today, I'd like to show you how to publish
your extension in the Google Chrome Extension
gallery.
Here on my desktop, I've got a new extension
that I've created. The first thing I'd like
to do is check that the manifest has a title,
a short description, and an icon. It's very
important to pay attention to these, as they'll
influence how likely people are to pick my
extension in the gallery.
Next I'm going to zip up this folder. There
are a number of free programs out there that
will do this for you. The gallery will require
me to upload this zip file, not a packaged
extension.
Next, I go to the gallery site at chrome.google.com/extensions.
I click the developer link here in the left
navigation, which takes me to my developer
dashboard. Here I can see all the extensions
that I've previously uploaded.
I click add new item, and the first thing
I have to do is upload the zip file I created
earlier.
At this point, I get taken to the edit page,
where I can enter a more detailed description.
I've already prepared this, so I'm just going
to paste it here. I can also add a support
link, which is very important to avoid users
posting bug reports in my reviews.
I'm also going to add some nice screenshots.
Again, the nicer my extension looks, the bigger
the chance that someone will install it.
I can also specify a youtube video. Ideally
this would be a screencast of my extension
in action.
Finally, when all is ready, I hit publish
and get taken to a preview page. Here I double-check
my information and confirm.
In just a few minutes, my extension is live
in the Google Chrome Extension gallery! I
hope to see yours there soon too.